environmental groups are applauding the
landmark ruling for a formal school
groundskeeper in his years-long battle
with the chemical giant Monsanto the
jury found the company at fault for
allowing the man to contract cancer
after using its popular weed killer for
years John Blackstone reports Dwayne
Johnson a 46 year old father of three
doesn't have long to live his doctors
say he claims his cancer non-hodgkins
lymphoma was caused by the Monsanto weed
killer roundup in what is regarded as a
precedent-setting case a jury in San
Francisco agreed
did you find by clear and convincing
evidence that Monsanto acted with malice
or oppression in the conduct upon which
you base your finding of liability in
favor of mr. Johnson answer yes
in total the jury awarded Johnson nearly
290 million dollars in damages this case
has been very hard it's been fought long
it took a lot of years to get here the
jury heard evidence that Monsanto knew
roundup was dangerous and could cause
cancer but hid that fact from consumers
the trial attracted prominent
environmental activists including the
singer Neil Young and Robert F Kennedy
jr. and I'm so glad this held them
accountable Johnson had worked as a
groundskeeper for a school district in
the San Francisco Bay Area he claimed to
use Monsanto's weed killer up to 30
times a year spraying hundreds of
gallons of it during the trial
Monsanto's attorneys argued there was no
evidence roundup causes cancer and after
the verdict Monsanto Vice President
scott partridge insisted glyphosate the
active ingredient in roundup is safe it
doesn't change the overwhelming
scientific evidence and the 40 years of
safe use of glyphosate around the world
but Johnson's lawyer urged the jurors to
hold Monsanto liable and punish them
with a verdict that would as he put it
it actually changes the world I think
I'm glad to be here to be able to help
with a cause is way bigger than me
Dewayne Johnson's case was separated
from some 5,000 others waiting to make a
similar claim against Monsanto he was
allowed to go first because of the
advanced
age of his disease and the possibility
he wouldn't live to see a verdict
Monsanto says it will appeal this
verdict precede us this morning Saturday
John Blackstone San Francisco